alright guys I'm here with John McAfee
flew all the way down to Exuma to do an
interview
thank you very much that makeup oh
thanks family John is in rare form and
and ready to go alright so first let's
just talk about your background I don't
think a lot of people know you start out
working with NASA person let's fun what
my learnings I just started yesterday
half of my teeth and she really thought
for me as much as I can
starting NASA no no what did you do for
you okay
and then what you do after NASA just
[ __ ] well you guys ended up at
Lockheed Martin all right and when you
ended up at Lockheed Martin the brain
virus right they gave me sneeze
sometimes you and say they figure out
how to stop this I don't know if I see
it's a program that doesn't exist that's
how crazy I'm [ __ ] Donuts and the to
my job so top-secret security clearance
the engine questions like did you [ __ ]
don't the jobs you don't need why did
you ever get the drugs
and so I thought I'm gonna get this to
these later came through and I think
because it's questions like did you ever
take bugs yes
what kind yeah the Jews held up Spears
well God everything you can't black
because I'm [ __ ] secret alright and
so what what was the genesis for the
idea for McAfee the antivirus software
it was an accident
so my brother-in-law a width of the up
is anything
this pocket put it up on my book the
court system and forgot
then I'm legal
and so when you personally the company
though you started while you're at
Lockheed right and then when you went
full time you were to sign it into
corporations with they just didn't have
any other solutions or well first period
but I can't get hundreds of requests per
day for help
settlement is is trying to gun me so
into corporations my first month you
made eleven million dollars your first
one that's that you realize that's
incredible right especially was it's
like late 80s eleven million dollars in
lady he's a lot more than eleven nine
dollars a day all right so you did that
and then you sold your stake in the
company pretty early right like before
it became as big as it is today he wants
to do that
I was bored you're bored that was more
all right everything's really doing good
stuff so basically you enjoyed the
technical parts we didn't like the part
of actually running the company oh no
all right anywhere myself all right
and and busines and that as you were
after you sold the stake in the company
the internet bubble hit right what was
that like what do you remember about the
internet bubble in the late nineties
okay women maybe with both have a lot of
people turned their Google people okay
through time okay
Yahoo in the Google people on this or
home who's Chinese I stupidly listen
either okay you didn't have all right
and and then how much of it is similar
to what we saw to he with the
cryptocurrency boom versus differences
in Internet are the same they're all the
same
the people who can see yeah this is not
a hunt if they invest other two they
can't have it they fell short and then
real thing happens like Bitcoin I don't
hear it's a penny today there's gonna be
two properties racer see so even if the
Bitcoin depending today you think the
solution I'm here to $9 why should I
care
yeah because you guys look at your life
you get nothing
all right and so as you're going to the
Internet boom you eventually start
making a bunch of investment in real
estate right and housing Christmas well
some of it okay what so what is it
what's really really new 8 all right so
that's why I came all the way here to
hear from you I has to do that's for it
ok all right after the Internet you made
a bunch of investment right yes just
talk about what were you investing in it
well let's see some companies
first up with some labs ok to check for
software girls oh okay and then but you
also did non tech investing then was
only this whole bunch of really super
cool okay a bunch of really cool houses
by herself and right in this book which
he poured it concrete yep I hit it carve
and carve understand stone and built a
50,000 square foot mansion Wow it was a
piece of art alright and then and then
that's what this story was talking about
in terms of the housing crisis the
original it was stuff sir hence we went
down both so
at the time of the housing crisis you at
61 lawsuits and then once everyone
realized hey he didn't have as much
money as we thought he did lawsuits
disappear except they're back of course
yeah
was less about crypto when did you first
discover a big quietly 2003-2011 and do
you remember what that first like they
send you some Bitcoin or one from a guy
named Jim Zaromskis really did two or
three different companies work for me
okay
ripping generation said it goes my pipe
good for you so she wasn't eleven
somebody worked for you basically said
hey I'm mining crypto at in the back we
said I'm going to believe we're great
what I'm coming to make you do something
maybe agree with Lisa so she's like okay
so he makes you read the nine page white
paper what was your thoughts when you
read it I'm a mathematician that's what
my training is anyway yep no college out
of state they work University University
also do you manage any politic okay
every not every dog that's all know what
at the paper
I saw a thousand years instant okay
which is why I know
and so when used to read the white paper
what do you do first you just you know
that hey this is the future do you make
investments you start mining you would
do first
nothing I just totally okay kind of June
was mining make you a fortune that's
before before the person - yep 4G Hong
Lou yep who by him like the most humble
[ __ ] on this guy and people
throw stones at him I want to go to
[ __ ] eyes out I'm telling the truth
is one of my best friends humble you
know nice study the woman or that's home
Alan and push back so you're talking
about G Hollywood CEO and so what was
the first thing eventually you did
you're known as a huge crypto balls so
you see the future it really doesn't let
me just put you bought a million dollars
in manera why Manero first but I was
privacy because you're a huge proponents
privacy plans they say do you realize
for some of you don't if you send me an
ethereal over to going to encode forever
master I see everything anyway welcome
when how much - it's not vegetable so
what you're talking about is once
somebody sent you in on privacy based
coin you know what their wallet is and
you watch everyone every transaction
forever
okay certainly outside solution dick but
it's beef when youth first started with
the security software right before the
internet was really popular there was a
there's a huge debate around encryption
and eventually though proponents of
encryption one and now we have a more
private Internet today because of the
encryption do you think that every point
will adopt the privacy features are we
going definitely privacy okay so you
please fine is it go ahead I don't want
that to be private especially I'm
successful wait you don't want so you
think that some points will have privacy
some points don't need it and so what
about bit conservative you think it'd be
fun will amend we adopt the privacy
aspects though yeah but however it going
a little bit and it's really big college
said ok see you think that Bitcoin
becomes the future gold standard the
global reserve BSC right and there were
other coins that had very specific
see features that are therefore read
yeah you know the consequence follow
safe X is a great point
all right closer members Apollo
seatbacks Manero
Z cash huh as you ain't guess would
people want to know where your
investments today what will you hold
listens the crooked person wears fine
that's your nothing all right
no this boat this watch I have a piece
of paper for this honkophone and from a
dude so much overwatch alright nice
alright
you own nothing and so as you think of
crypto right Bitcoin becomes the global
reserve currency what's what do you
think we have to do to get to the point
where crypto is pervasive across the
world right what are the things that
have to happen for mass adoption have to
have a better finish
okay so that mothers plumbers shoemakers
on people's doors for huge chemical cut
all right so basically for the adoption
to occur you need better user
experiences use right that's what should
I look certain system actually I want to
[ __ ] me no I want some something than
mom
yep give me the mouth it's basically
missing every massive mass adoption user
is gonna need that you get user
interface that they're used to um unit
right they're not going to actually
understand all the cryptography and all
what do you think governments responses
as this stuff becomes the standard right
if it all sudden Bitcoin becomes our big
climbing um send a little dealership we
don't think the government's here is a
conflation they can trace it but do you
think it threatens that you can never do
it like do you think that you're a
threatened by in Syria of course but
their farm what's written by what I've
been saying for five okay okay what's
that privacy distributive exchange you
think that privacy and distributed
exchanges are more
of a threat and bitcoin is 200 yes
because we have the true distributive
sense and by the way I think it's which
this is the first one that I see has one
okay right and the privacy one
how's it no they can't they can't
stretch you down from exchanging because
the distributed exchange or decent how
they change their privacy they can't
track video thank you got and you think
those are the two biggest threats that
government that's right that's right so
so I promoted by jump people listeners
to tell you were fantastic
this is how you avoid the burden of them
all right and so one of the things that
is possible is that these decent Isaac
changes become the dominant way that
people exchange privacy points what's
the government's response to that organ
age does not happen their sponsors
legislation may get people but then what
you're smoking it's a good stopping you
they can't it's the same [ __ ] thing I
you know your brother shooting up heroin
yeah you talked about the fact that that
the government's are upset that you're
promoting some of this right I think a
lot of people in crypto know that you're
doing quantum today all the promotional
yes to talk about like what was the
genesis of the idea of doing that and
and how does that all work right did you
just get a bunch of inbound requests
until you pick them up you like I get
thousands a day that's pretty much the
mode or to look at I get him pronounce
some of the day there's so many requests
for the guys and that summer was so
[ __ ] good like say thanks yep and
just simply ain't got take a look at
this if we're all dudes in that city got
it and then they were then the drop is
every time I did that the device and the
coin with Twitter with triple and the
people get mad at you yeah so but when
you do these promotional tweets
people were paying you for them right
how did you come up with how much they
should pay what the market would which
is whatever people that I'm constantly
high-sided million half a million mostly
want to be our grand hundred fifty -
yeah it's not that we should run you
distant line and you guys $850,000 to
280 character food you rise that's crazy
right money no he's I've been switch
hundred times I made 200 200 put you're
doing rough yours
yeah crazy that's probably true in many
cases that that picture yes well don't
run the crazy no no you're not but the
fact that people are the fact that
people are willing to pay that money
right music playing okay my most
expensive lawsuit was a wrongful death
involving my fish okay he was flying an
airplane that took off from thanks for
property allegedly okay in an airplane
crash put himself and his passenger I
was by the same people who got fifty
billion dollars from the ribbon kind of
a final eight years eleven million
dollars and what do they want why are
they soon for the wrongful death my
nephew took off in an airplane in an
airplane
wrongful death just like this last fall
over 225 million bucks yeah so they're
just coming after you crazy yeah dude
what was the response to to the
promotional tweak do you think people
liked it did they learnt it they loved
it well people who are confident yeah
people basically view talked about their
coin they like it they're hopeful other
points did like this got it do you feel
like you would keep doing it or do you
think that it hey there's a point in
time where the promotional tweets were
important and now they're just not
that's a nice stock to go though
something if you're white up very much
below
people were too upset Oh do you regret
they did it no no I told you what I
thought yeah
so you just felt like something because
I still do it you know feel God he's
getting paid for this one maybe maybe
not that promise you are not collective
and as I fully believe this I'm feeling
you're having their contact miss Damien
got a great cook and a great concept if
you move on cardiac function okay so
basically you're only promoting things
that you fully believe in and this and
then you say to them hey 10 to 20
requests per day people get the point
yeah I take 100 maybe - all right that's
good
let's talk about politics you're running
for president but that's what you said
are you all right are you something
campaign down everywhere yes all right
so see but you're you've got this
platform right you're able to push a
campaign let's say that if you were to
actually run what's the playbook could
be knocked down from what does the
candidate need to do to the win to be
president today oh here why do these
things it Domino or Hillary Clinton or J
it has to do with a structure okay the
existing state of our government number
one wit know what the truth is we get
the line - while they spy not believe uh
using my money podcast because you let
me tapped by the bench by the NSA read
them off do you think that everyone you
think that every American is just
operating under the assumption that
we're all being spied on
I hope so because it's the truth yeah
there is no privacy in
in every country though oh no you think
there's some countries where they're not
actually spying always there absolutely
yeah
well what country would you say is the
best when it comes to privacy and
non-severe bone bowling
yeah it's pretty it's pretty many fellow
chokes to the bra but come from yes yeah
France yeah so you think that it's a
bunch of European countries all right
hold on Branson black bone beds uh India
Pakistan
yeah before so when I told people I was
coming to interview you I asked for
questions a lot of people want to know
your thoughts on issues around the
politics and around being the president
so I'm gonna read all topics totally
outside on the wall and immigration I
have no clue neither do you that's Trump
probably sees it we don't know the exact
numbers we don't know we don't know what
the truth of it we're a bunch of lies
that are collated if polished by the CIA
checked off by the NSA and every Monday
when trying to decide who to murder
police
what is forget all the numbers and
forget all of that stuff just if you
think about immigration in general so
the US have open borders closed borders
what should what should be approached me
at your poem what would you set the
standard
well unfolding language hum imagine
there's no country
[ __ ] me why should a imagine
prevent someone from taking step from
one part to another part of the desert
of the mountain please yeah so you think
that the borders being these imaginary
lines on a map actually are a huge
problem but yeah yes but for your throat
I'll take it first or not okay you're
something all right for the first four
years long
if someone has it now James knows right
now not being I knew all those swallows
happening
however the joke is first she cuts
anything I mentioned before spin I'm not
stupid I'm 73 for a reason you're trying
to kill me
48 years all right let's go back to the
political stuff what about a financial
regulation people you are living in a
soup bowl of [ __ ] you know nothing about
the truth because the government has
misled you
we were living lives of slaves getting
up in the morning commuting around to
work working in some irritants George
[ __ ] office 9 hours a day 5 days a
week the rest of your [ __ ] life and
you compete for that you want you want
to be a higher level slave no no me this
is your life instead of looking at your
life you won't ask me about financial
regulations on Wall Street
what does that have to do with your life
nothing
so to us
nothing the actions you do so and so
your whole thing here is the personal
free should shop everything else correct
without a lot yeah unfortunately who are
we so lemme SSO so I generally agree
that personal freedom should be the
standard but what do you think to the
people who say the things that you do
don't just affect do they affect other
people right if you go and you take a
bunch of drugs and then all of a sudden
you're driving and you run into somebody
or you do something crazy somebody gets
hurt right where's the line in terms of
what affects you versus affecting other
people which is leads analyzing what's
to say
what you want what this man said what if
I see marijuana I'm gonna kill somebody
know what he should say is what might be
just influence what it is please God
what might be what happens if I don't
take care one and I'm not not calm I'm
angry and I shoot somebody
christ almighty you can't read what
might happen influence if the [ __ ]
decision you ever made please God know
what might be give me anything what it
is this is the fact that you have
control of your body if you choose to
use that button to shoot somebody or the
rough somebody put asleep they take
drugs we click on control entire [ __ ]
work we can make our life sick life is
not safe I promise you
spike come here part of job security
team spies here spy introduce yourself
shot three times
so spies been stabbed in the eye and
shot three times so spotty can promise
you for your company life is not safe I
can promise you or me my life is far
less safe and spies and I think he will
life is not safe if you try to make it
safe you kill it you kill them energy
which invigorate and creates joy bliss
mystery what mystery is the knowing that
ah I'd say no one's gonna shoot me
pumping yes it on bed without Vaseline
no life is fine but that's no life let
me ask you this question I would say
that you live life
most more than 99% of other right do you
have any regrets in life this woman all
right what do you if you're president
will you do a space travel should we go
[Laughter]
I'm here comparisons present it was so
spiders you can so lied to truth Thanks
no I mean to say one thing
look at yourself now with response
paying taxes in the bank you're calling
out so god bless please and write me but
if you're not and stop by going off and
sometimes there's nothing to do the
situation or discomfort shuttle and my
mother hasn't blockage of polymers
please not see that you don't understand
anything about the people that elected
my one suggestion wrote them all huh
yet barely shut the [ __ ] sleep be
better
there'll be no couch
he's got just have years of collection
growing inside the government designed
to serve us when is the last time we
don't serve it you seriously sir do they
look like they are on masters and their
servants these will you get their heads
useful you sort of me as a president
which is lying on its like in prison
right what can compete what do you think
about a different mind-altering drug
what what is the things that you can use
on a daily basis to good with place that
you want to say what's Pittsburgh for
what for self-analysis for sleep for sex
the introspection love [ __ ] for her
favorite doll advisor but this is why
I'm so crazy
[Music]
what are driving something they are
substances that influence either the
body one per week you see luggage
yeah no we do it continents who are my
students can go to those things which
alter their perceptions of their
surroundings and more importantly of
themselves
Tom what that sounds you know what
here's why I'm asking ready I think that
a lot of people hear about bath salts
they read about these crazy stories etc
they've got no clue what a bath salt is
they don't know how it works what he
does to your mind accessor
oh [ __ ] Isabella the salt this is not a
class
though poorly this man's death salt is
the name given to every new research
chemical which is mind-altering okay
billion why better salt producer I was
advising legal defense hot passions has
bath salts people no no hang it's on DVD
and there's under the salts not good you
know about in DBMS on suppose a put one
ten from one kilogram in four baths for
instead but that we don't do that
because what does it do when you take
them and in terms of this the middle in
the back basically what is it though
that is it that's hot it wouldn't change
though
sauces a way of shopping a new job you
get somebody knows legal I'd say George
it was seven of your eyes burn jet no
something that's great do you Thomas to
that's all I'd take 100 Mike's dissolve
me job and [ __ ] it means midnight as
well in these it's just way to produce
it's just it's different vernacular for
it's covered in trucks all right so all
right so let's switch from drugs to just
more general questions in terms of when
you think of your life
are you happy then this app is anybody
you see them happy
I'm very happy oh yeah wasn't that they
can attend it so when John says carving
is Ravin to do the interview on the boat
because as he was jumping off the boat
the other night
Torres Achilles tendon but it's not a
good day function is awesome right
what is the average day like what do you
do every day you're enjoying life I live
in your life what would he say that your
day like this
you don't have an understanding of wake
up in the morning that's why every
person that I've met loves you and says
similar things around how much fun
you're having
- what would you say to the people
online specifically that say negative
things or the haters what did they not
understand about you that you wish that
they understood number one lunging
thought what we're doing to people about
me I don't know how much you trash me
put my species if you're not giving them
you love you have dreams of course
generous compassionate gentle loving you
are also April block fearful greedy
we're all so you're on ratings on one
part of your back which is I hate you I
understand fully I love you so let's go
that's right don't give a [ __ ] what I
think your pain because you can't touch
me
what you say about me can't touch me
even shooting at me generally you have
to be you as you are trouble Dennis wing
I love that you love the trolls yeah
they all come around eventually right
right right
all right sue you run and do much a
legal trouble what's the whole situation
you've got everything from taxes to
documentaries you ignore everything
leaving lawsuits Bob that's on the
touchpad what's the difference so this
Netflix documentary exploded everyone
was talking about it for a while you
have to not know you did watch it one
minute
well it's a waste of time yeah Oh God
all right so you didn't watch it and
then you've consistently over the last
what maybe 10 years you've moved between
Belize Guatemala the u.s. down the
Bahamas etc how much of it is deal with
what what's the most dangerous situation
you've been mostly Mustaine just happen
on December 13 December 13th
oh thanks my last world I was thinking I
was women why because I was in the
bottom on Jill with a more precision God
I mean I couldn't understand the
television station so all I could do was
[ __ ] I always had to be without a woman
mothering all the Kim Savannah girls
this is how it works in other countries
very reasonable the other jail drugs in
your purse why not not money so in here
I'm sitting in a coffee shop
god dammit really I did not have his
good coffee in some coffee in the
country what produces the best coffee
why couldn't you Argentine real Connie
they have my machine
all right
you may at the time very popular Bitcoin
price prediction that it's going to half
million then you went to the million
dollars you're considering going to two
million but you set a million dollars by
there like 20 or you eat your dick
alright
sticking by it click it alright do two
questions for you that everyone really
wants to know one are you gonna do it on
national television
what depends I mean this way I'm gonna
have my this I don't do work for myself
everyone knows I don't have contract it
now you don't do work yourself alright
so there's a place in Bangkok done this
beautiful prostitutes world they consent
day for hours sometimes days I'm
contracted with 30 of them on a relay
team with the Association keep trying
John de alright really yes Bobby G why
would you up to two million dollars
there's a bucket
[Laughter]
alright that's fair but what do you
think is gonna happen to bitcoins price
if you really think it's gonna go to a
million - Tony - next level years
notices you got doing the [ __ ]
numbers do he'll have said well bitcoins
going up in value these prices are going
down what's gonna happen when the
reality kicks red and everybody's [ __ ]
using it and it's really worth a billion
dollars a [ __ ] coin it was really if
it's he
Karthi this is goddamn Valley something
many formerly oh please God one of those
numbers yeah so your [ __ ] you may hear
is that I teach math in school the
fundament your argument is the
fundamental value continues to increase
regardless of where the price goes up
yes please God
yeah mister alright before I wrap up I
always ask rapid-fire questions listen
by the way your voices hold up great
great job what's the most important
company good name bit me
wait why beat me to the G huh so I spend
up my stinking Jihan your boy isn't a
humble man I've ever [ __ ] he's also
just parties do you realize it Bitcoin
there's nothing more than a personal
it's a hobby for him
then the answer mine and everything he
has done video hobby it's true interest
is artificial intelligence and that's
all this is built basic process is a
process that one looks at ago the
presidency God so I did you [ __ ] what
people think about why they say too much
power me who cares
Senay hands are humble [ __ ] yeah
you know thank you storage what's the
most controversial thought yeah what's
the one thing you believe that everyone
else will disagree that could come and
will be challenged and turbulence into
our economy or society or beliefs your
personal relationships and certainly
into our awareness of ourselves and what
how it really is then we'll make the
Industrial Revolution
look like a kindergarten sandbox game
I cannot put into words what's coming
down the spine I see it kind of like
words for it just like this that word
for meeting before me up here so I can't
tell you I see it and I promise you it
is coming it is coming and be strong and
survive and bring that joy and freedom
here too I come long with it
what's the one regulation you change
your I think of the trying one
regulation that says other people can
regulate you just get rid of regulation
in jail that's her when uh what's the
most important book ever read Charles
Darwin's Origin it's his hands down why
tell you why number one find the only
person might feel of acquaintances in my
entire [ __ ] life is written why did I
well I was living with them in Mexico
for you I was desperate to read them I
can't pay on these [ __ ] backwards
Mexican trailer parks like they it's
boring I wanted a book the only English
was in Guadalajara Thomas our origins
piece and by means of natural selection
they won't [ __ ] me and this is English I
read it two or three times its minute
are you that book I promise
be like talking to do horse it doesn't
matter female packaging marketing and
you know the call your email is on will
fly to you people who have read Charles
Darwin's or returns a piece was cooked
up should email you at McAfee Nomad as
you know calm and if I can't come to
power here to me because I've never got
to see him
he's read the Balkan sugar every we all
talk evolution [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't
know anything so no we the beauty I mean
heads here's my eyes should've hit
readings the beauty the inside the depth
that yeah I viewed that I would give
everything that know which is just
before I finish let you ask me a
question I'll ask questions always about
aliens yes you believe in aliens you are
one with are you the only alien or you
think there's other aliens we are all
aliens misspoke why because I don't care
who you are which looks like what's your
sex is watching ages who are you it's
nobody like you there's never been
anybody like you
and there never will be any like you you
are one of the unique creature thing the
sparks from life created for you for you
would you rather go to the depths of the
ocean or go to space
there's one of you more scared of I
don't want you out of it you don't ready
to hunt the first person didn't pay
people would people go I know would you
like to be alone so I don't do bats or
some back hug or house that's why they
know how to party merciless alright
before we end what one question do you
have for me by the [ __ ] do you can
waddle the girl here just above today so
I wanted you to tell your story in your
work I think there's a lot of people who
are who are super interested in what you
got to say but no one gives you a
platform to just say what you believe UN
force people to listen to my god those
listening we are in Exuma Bahamas and
and we walked up to the bar your spare
time these days yes alright I always
somebody that's fun I appreciate you